ما هي رسالتك أه حسن
اليقظة الذهنية هو حقًا الوعي
والحضور وكلما نكتسب وعيًا بما
يحدث
في أفكارنا وفي عواطفنا أه
نحن قادرون على الرد على ما
يحدث في عالمنا بمهارة أكثر
لذلك الكثير منا أه يعيش على الطيار الآلي
نحن نتعامل مع التوتر ونتعامل مع
القلق
الذي نستجيب له من خلال الوقوع
في
عادات التأقلم غير القادرة على التكيف أه أو
أنك تعلم الوقوع في حالة من الإرهاق دون
الاهتمام بأنفسنا حقًا ،
لذا فإن اليقظة الذهنية تتيح لنا ملاحظة
ما يحدث في أذهاننا ما
ما نحتاجه هو أن قلوبنا تتسارع ، هل نحن متوترون ،
هل نحن قلقون ، هل نحتاج إلى التوقف مؤقتًا ،
هل نحتاج إلى أخذ نفس ، هل نحتاج
إلى تغيير شيء ما
في حياتنا ، وحتى نتمكن من
تغيير علاقتنا
بما يحدث ويمكننا فقط
يمكننا التعامل بمهارة أكثر حقًا ، فهذه
واحدة من أكبر الطرق التي أعتقد
أننا نساعد بها الناس الآن
، وسيكون من المفيد حقًا الحصول على بعض
النصائح
منك أه بالنظر إلى العديد من
يمر الناس جميعًا في هذا الوقت
ببعض النصائح حول الحفاظ على الهدوء
واليقظة خلال هذه الفترة ،
نعم بالتأكيد حتى تعرف مرة أخرى
العودة للوعي ،
أحد أهم
الأشياء هو مجرد ملاحظة
أنك تعرف أه الكثير منا يريد  حتى يتم
إعلامنا بذلك ، فنحن نشاهد الأخبار التي نتواجد بها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
فنحن ملتصقون
بشاشاتنا ولا ندرك حقيقة أن
ذلك يؤدي إلى تفاقم توترنا وقلقنا ،
لذا يجب الانتباه ومراقبة
كمية الأخبار
التي نستهلكها  نحن نأخذ
وخلق أنشطة الرعاية والتأسيس أه
التي يمكننا الاعتماد
عليها وعندما نشعر
بالإرهاق وكذلك
الذهاب في نزهة نتأمل القراءة
والرقص والبستنة ،
أي شيء يساعدنا في مواجهة
هذا عدم اليقين
أنت تعرف أن أحد أسهل
الأشياء التي يجب القيام بها
عندما نتعامل مع القلق هو أن
تتكثف في النفس ، حيث يكون التنفس
دائمًا معنا وهو مخبر رائع
لما يحدث معنا إذا كان
لدينا  يكون الجو
سريعًا وإذا كان غير منتظم ، فسنجد غالبًا أننا
غارقون أو قلقون ، وإذا استطعنا
معرفة أن أبسط
تمرين استنشاق ببطء شديد
والزفير ببطء شديد ، فإنه يحفز
نظامنا العصبي الباراسمبثاوي ،
ونحن قادرون على الاسترخاء.  الجهاز العصبي الخلوي
لذلك يمكن أن يكون مفيدًا للغاية